bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
au parlement européen à strasbourg pour
cette édition d'europe et aux nouvelles
émissions et nouveau décor oui katia et
dans cette émission nous irons à paimpol
en bretagne une ville qui testent un
champ d'hydroliennes une machine qui
permet de produire de l'électricité
grâce aux courants marins
mais d'abord l'actualité les dirigeants
européens sont tombés d'accord pour
faire l'union bancaire mais alors est ce
que les banquiers compte plus que les
citoyens c'est la question impertinente
de la semaine c'était mal parti en train
guélat merkel et françois hollande en
désaccord sur le sujet numéro un
à l'ordre du jour du dernier sommet
européen l'union bancaire
paris veut aller vite faire la réforme
avant la fin de l'année mais pour berlin
cela revient à foncer dans le mur
le président et la chancelière finissent
de s'expliquer dans les couloirs et
quelques heures plus tard surprise ils
tombent d'accord
l'union bancaire se fera plus tôt que
prévu comme le souhaitait la france elle
se mettra en oeuvre à partir du 1er
janvier dès lors que le cadre législatif
aura été adopté mais l'allemagne a posé
ses conditions
notre ministère des finances travaille
sur ce dossier mais nous voulons réussir
quelque chose de solide donc l'union
bancaire ne se mettra pas en place avant
la fin de l'année 2013
une fois le système en place toutes les
banques de la zone euro sans exception
seront placées sous l'égide d'un
surveillant unique la banque centrale
européenne qui sera assistée des dix
sept banques centrales de la zone euro
personne ne pourra plus dissimulé de
bombe cachée dans son bilan sans que big
brother ne soit au courant
et désormais si une banque un problème
elle pourra demander l'aide directe du
mécanisme européen de stabilité sans que
les états donc les contribuables mettent
la main à la poche
il aura donc fallu trois ans de travail
de discussions de négociations pour
tenter d'assainir le système bancaire
européen mais les citoyens ont
l'impression que les dirigeants portent
moins d'attention à leurs problèmes
qu'ils sont moins mobilisés quand il
s'agit de sauver le programme erasmus ou
bien l'aide alimentaire aux plus pauvres
alors les banquiers sont ils plus que
les citoyens voient là et nous sommes
revenus à strasbourg un député nous a
rejoint jean paul gauzès bonjour bonjour
vous êtes membre de la commission des
affaires économiques ici au parlement
européen et vous siéger au sein du
groupe ppe qui rassemble les partis de
droite et de centre-droit en europe
alors je vous ai vu réagir pendant ce
sujet vous connaissez bien là le monde
de la banque puisque vous y aviez même
travaillé il ya quelques années
est ce que pour vous on en a pas un peu
trop fait pour les banquiers on a vu que
depuis 2008 il ya eu beaucoup de
gouvernements qui ont volé au secours de
banques mal en point aujourd'hui on met
en place une union bancaire est ce que
ça va se faire au détriment du citoyen
ou est-ce que ça n'a rien à voir non ça
ne sera pas au détriment de citoyens
c'est au contraire pour rassurer et pour
donner de la solidité au aussi seulement
de terre le système bancaire est
important alors il ya des déviations il
ya eu des spéculations abusive
il ya eu beaucoup d'erreurs qui ont été
faites mais le système dans lequel est
important parce que c'est lui qui
fournit l'énergie dont a besoin
l'économie pour fonctionner est ce
l'objectif
finalement c'est premièrement de faire
en sorte que les halles finances soit au
service de l'économie réelle et
deuxièmement qu'elle ne se laisse pas
aller à des pratiques qui ont été tout à
fait dommageable est-ce que typiquement
ça va permettre le fait de confier à une
autorité unique la banque centrale
européenne le contrôle des banques est
ce que ça va permettre d'éviter demain
des affaires du type affaire kerviel
oui et non l'objectif évidemment c'est
d'assurer un contrôle surtout un
contrôle qui soit plus impartial comme
contrôle national c'est pour ça qu'il ya
une supervision belge signale que le
parlement l'avait demandée en 2010 et
que nous avions donné toute l'
architecture possible à l'époque les
états membres n'ont pas voulu sans
réfléchir maintenant il revient bien sûr
parce qu'on a gagné 3 ans voulaient y
ait trois ans et c'était appréciable
mais des affaires comme kerviel pourront
toujours arriver
c'est comme quand j'étais à votr me
disais mais pourquoi on n'interdit pas
le vol le vol est réprimée mais il n'est
pas interdit ça suffit pas et d'aller
contre on peut toujours qu'on peut
toujours aller contrôler de façon de
très fines
mais pour ça il faut beaucoup de monde
et c'est coûteux et deuxièmement quand
comme dans le calcaire vielle vous avez
défauts qui sont faits c'est à dire que
l'on fait une mante une manoeuvre
d'escroquerie à ce moment là la
perception de l'estro trier est
difficile dans un système compliqué faut
un certain temps pour s'apercevoir vous
dites que les banques ça aussi pour
fonction de prêter de l'argent à ceux
qui en ont besoin et notamment les
jeunes entrepreneurs les patrons de
petites et moyennes entreprises
est ce que demain avec ce système met en
place d' union bancaire les banques
seront plus enclins plus généreuse
prêteront plus facilement de l'argent à
ces à ces acteurs économiques qui en la
supervision ne devrait pas avoir d'effet
particulier sur sa en revanche les
règles qui sont en préparation sur
l'appel crd4 c'est à dire les besoins en
fonds propres des banques
ça c'est très sont de nature c'est
compliqué mais c'est de nature à limiter
la possibilité de crédit sallie la
partie de montmort où on veut plus de
sécurité moins de risques dans les
banques
évidemment on est en empêche l'effet
multiplicateur et donc il n'est pas
impossible que les crédits deviennent
moins disponibles qu'il n'était si on
met une réglementation de sancerre le
problème c'est l' équilibre entre la
sécurité le risque et l'aide à
l'économie
je crois que ce qui faut améliorer c'est
la mesure du risque mesuré l du risque
c'est pas parce qu'on demande des
crédits konya droit c'est parce qu'on
fait des activités qui sont bien
encadrés
mais dont le risque est maîtrisé on peut
obtenir des crédits alors avec l'union
bancaire désormais n'est les états
c'est-à-dire les contribuables ni
d'interview ne rompt pas directement au
secours d'une banque si elle est est ce
que c'est ça n'est pas directement
l'effet de l'union bancaire non plus
vous c est compliqué mais c'était la
condition pour l'allemagne accepte que
le fonds de secours européen puisse
intervenir parce qu'ils pensent que s'il
y avait un contrôle sur une supervision
européenne elle sera mieux fait et -10
questionnaire que si elle est faite au
niveau national bien que par exemple en
france le contrôle des membres se fait
d'une façon tout à fait efficace dans
votre pays mais c'est pas forcément le
cas dans tous les pays prennent par
exemple les allemands ne voudrais vous
ne voulez pas mais il change de point de
vue controller caisse d'epargne mais il
voulait contrôler clé c'est par une
espagnole contradictoire quand même tout
à fait contradictoires mais c'est un des
aspects aussi l'europe mais le
cette ses meilleurs contrats pour les
contribuables ont posé la question des
contribuables les bons contrôles permet
d'éviter les erreurs ou les où les
difficultés mais le deuxième aspect de
ce mécanisme du dew bancaire ce sera la
mise en place d'un système de résolution
des crises des banques avec par les
banques elles-mêmes
c'est à dire la création d'un fonds qui
permettra au cas où une banque prédit
difficulté qu'on s'adresse à ceux pour
remettre les choses au point et non plus
haut au trésor public c'est à dire comme
le disait il ya quelques mois le
commissaire européen michel barnier
désormais s'il ya un problème les
banques paieront pour les banques et ce
ne sont plus les états les banques
paieront pour les banques la condition
de le problème aux photographes c'est à
dire que le fonds qui sera une assurance
en quelque sorte et les moyens
nécessaires pour faire face à chris
c'est vrai que c'est pour ça qu'il faut
arriver un système supervision efficace
au niveau repères parce que si toutes
les banques avaient une prise au même
moment bien là le fond aussi grand
soit-il ne permettrait pas de régler la
question
donc il faut éviter la reproduction de
risque systémique c'est à dire du
système bancaire comme on l'a vu dans
les années qui viennent de s'écouler
alors ya un risque est toujours présent
en europe en espagne la banque bank ya
est très mal emploi est très mal en
point
d'ailleurs c'est un sujet central de
préoccupation du gouvernement espagnol
mais typiquement 7,7 cette union
bancaire ne va pas être utile pour
l'espagne que se passera-t-il si
l'espagne a besoin de cet argent mais
maintenant si l'espèce est un jardin
dans normalement le ms ne pourra pas
fonctionner puisque les allemands ont
fait une condition de la supervision
européenne de la mise en jeu de ces
sommes il faudra bien trouver d'autres
solutions
mais s'ils voulaient l'exemple espagnol
montre à la fois montrent les limites
supervision nationales lorsqu'il ya eu
des tests en espagne n'était sont été
plutôt positif et puis tout d'un coup on
s'aperçoit que c'était pas la réalité
donc c'est pour ça que les allemands
notamment ont voulu cette union bancaire
on en reparlera très prochainement avec
vous merci beaucoup jean paul gauzès
d'avoir été sur europe et de dos alors
on va parler d'un autre sujet on va
parler de david cameron qui a ouvert les
hostilités sur le budget européen il a
dit qu'il mettrait son veto en cas
d'augmentation des ressources
déclarations tonitruantes alors que dans
les rues de londres
les crises se faisait plus fort pour
dénoncer la politique d'austérité c'est
à la une de notre zapping européen
regarder
ma position est très simple répond pas
un accord satisfaisant sur le budget
européen
si mes partenaires soit des
augmentations massives de décence le
premier ministre britannique david
cameron a donné des gages à sa majorité
conservatrice il refusera toute dérive
du budget européen
il souhaite de budget séparé l'un pour
les 17 pays de la zone euro et le second
pour les dix autres dont le royaume uni
mon chiffre du jour
je crois que 16% des fonctionnaires
européens gagnent plus de 100 mille
euros par an eh bien au royaume uni au
contraire nous réduisons les dépenses
des fonctionnaires c'est de
l'administration centrale
l'austérité ça ne marche pas c'est le
slogan phare de l'imposante
manifestation qui a envahi le centre de
londres ce samedi
ni les syndicats ni la police n'ont
fourni d'estimation mais les
protestataires étaient assurément des
dizaines de milliers je n'accepte pas
cette idée de dire que notre pays serait
un poids pour l'europe
nous sommes au contraire un acteur très
important et incontournable au sein de
l'union and him florencio voilà alors
nous sommes avec clémentine forissier
bonjour je vous êtes rédactrice en chef
de réactifs point fr le site d'info
numéro un sur les politiques européennes
alors david cameron
a prévenu si ça ne se passe pas comme il
le souhaite il mettra son veto au budget
européen le budget européen qui n'est
même pas encore en cours de discussion
est ce que c'est pas un peu dur comme
comme position est-ce que c'est lui qui
va donner le ton de la prochaine
discussion budgétaire
les britanniques sont toujours dans
cette position dans les négociations
budgétaires à long terme parce qu'on
parle d'un budget sur sept ans pour la
négociation de l'ue c'est pas étonnant
qu'il fasse un peu le la pluie et le
beau temps ça arrive à chaque fois ce
qui est bizarre c'est cette position
très radicale avant même que le sommet
de dons qui a lieu en fin novembre entre
les dirigeants européens aient commencé
et c'est vrai que négocient arriver une
négociation en disant je dirais non
quoi qu'il arrive étant donné que les
propositions actuellement sur la table
sont plutôt quand même au dessus de ce
qu'ils souhaitent c'est un peu étrange
est ce qu'il est en position de force
notamment face à l'allemagne
un gala merkel qui a prévenu que si les
choses allaient comme ça peut-être que
que certains rendez vous européen serait
seront annulés c'est ce qu'elle a dit
dans le 'financial times' est ce que ça
laisse augurer de discussion vraiment
très tendue on voit déjà que les
britanniques en tout cas en coulisses où
la porte c'est à dire que après
justement la réaction d'angela merkel
qui a dit je ne viendrai pas si jamais
c'est pour ne pas discuter je ne
viendrai pas certains porte parole de
cameron ont dit bon c'est une
négociation qui réouvre la porte donc
moi je pense que de toute façon tout le
monde sera là et tout le monde va se
mettre autour de la table pour discuter
alors précisons que c'est un budget qui
est donc réduit puisqu'il n'y a pas
beaucoup de sous et que certains pays
poussent pour augmenter là pour mettre
plus d'argent au pot commun c'est celui
d'hier au pouvoir notamment financé
certaines
certaines politiques la passation de
cameron pour qu'on la comprenne bien
c'est qu'il ne veut pas du tout qu'ils
aient la moindre augmentation c'est ça
non il va un gel des dépenses de façon
globale ce qui est ce qui réduirait en
réalité le budget à long terme de
l'union européenne et ce qui est sa
position elle est vraiment dur par
rapport à celle qui est celle de la
commission européenne et même par
rapport à celle de l'allemagne qui est
légèrement en dessous qui circulent en
ce moment alors il a même proposé une
piste pour réduire les dépenses couper
dans les salaires des fonctionnaires
européens est ce que c'est du vent ou
est-ce que
si vous pensez de cette île est pas le
seul en fait ça sur ce point là tout le
monde est d'accord ça fait des années
que les états essaient de dire à la
commission il faut que vous coupiez dans
les salaires de hauts fonctionnaires
donner l'exemple exactement parce que
nous on le fait au plan national d'oka
pas de raison que vous ne fassiez pas
mais c'est un mécanisme un peu
particulier tout ce qui concerne
notamment les salaires des
fonctionnaires les états s'étaient
engagés par le passé à ce qu'ils soient
indexées sur l'inflation de qu'en fait
ils avaient accepté pendant un certain
nombre d'années que les salaires
augmentent régulièrement et donc il ya
eu une bataille qui s'est engagé entre
la commission et les états ça finira par
changer mais pour l'instant disons
cameron n'est pas le seul à faire cette
demande
alors pour l'instant les voix sont un
peu discordante entre la france
l'allemagne la grande-bretagne est ce
que dans ces conditions un terrain
d'entente est possible sur un sujet
quand même important il faut que qu'un
terrain d'entente soit trouvé parce que
personne n'a intérêt en réalité même pas
les britanniques à ce qu'on trouve pas
un accord sur le budget à long terme de
lieu parce que si on trouve pas d'accord
c'est les bus et le budget de l'année
précédente
pour schématiser qui sera utilisé comme
référence pendant les trois prochaines
années et donc en réalité les
britanniques qui veulent par exemple
baisser le budget agricole et augmenter
le budget de la recherche ne
n'obtiendront pas gain de cause
donc on va trouver une solution comme
toujours en europe merci clémentine
forissier d'avoir été avec nous alors on
va parler justement de certains fonds
européens qui sont utiles qui figure au
budget européen s'écarte du feder le
fonds européen de développement régional
en bretagne il a servi par exemple à
mettre en place un champ d'hydroliennes
on va en parler dans un instant n'aura
hamadi recevra michèle rivasi mais
voyons d'abord à quoi ressemblent ces
énergies reportage de pierre lascars
à quelques centaines de mètres de saint
malo sous cette route on exploite
l'énergie de la mer depuis bientôt 40
ans l'usiné marémotrice de la rance
produit de l'électricité pour plus de
235 mille personnes soit l'équivalent de
la ville de rennes et le principe est on
ne peut plus simple lorsque la mère
arrive à marée haute
on ferme l'ensemble des vannes ce qui
fait que la mère est en prison et en
bassin une fois que la mer descend et
qu'elle est descendue suffisamment sur
les usines marémotrices à peu près 4 m
on ouvre on ouvre les vannes ce qui
permet de halo de passer à travers les
turbines et produire de l'électricité
problème une usine marémotrice ne peut
être installé que sur un vaste bras de
mer avec d'importants coefficients de
marée des contraintes géographiques qui
ont poussé edf à se tourner vers une
nouvelle technologie l'hydrolien essayé
dans les environs de paimpol toujours en
bretagne que sont testés ces nouvelles
machines le fonctionnement de cette
turbine de 16 mètres de diamètre est
comparable à celui d'un moulin l'hélice
est immergé par 35 mètres de fond et est
mis en mouvement par les courants marins
l'énergie produite par la rotation des
turbines est transformée en électricité
plus acheminé à terre par un câble
jusqu'à un transformateur raccordés au
réseau électrique
le courant est ensuite distribuée aux
particuliers vincent denby wilkes qui
pilote le projet voit dans cette
nouvelle technologie
un gage de fiabilité prometteur au
regard des autres énergies renouvelables
sionnel énergique présente cette grande
caractéristique d'être absolument
prévisible et prévisible des heures et
des années à l'avancé puisque on connaît
des années à l'avance ce qu'est
l'alternance des bars et l'amplitude de
ces marais leur de ces marais et donc on
sera très exactement à quel moment on
produit ce qui est un avantage
extrêmement important pour des énergies
renouvelables sheckley les
caractéristiques du solaire ou de
l'éolien c'est que son dégénéré un
terminal intermittente avec une
prédictibilité qui était difficile
implanté de telles machines sous la mer
revient à empiéter sur l'espace de
travail des marins pêcheurs
mais du côté du comité local des pêches
on a depuis longtemps accepté le partage
de l'océan tout ce qui appartenait pas
virtuellement pêcheurs il ya 40 ans ou
50 ans la bande côtière c'est de son
monde n'y avait pas de présence et ipad
énergies marines et pas d'acteurs qui
avait que lui gaieté en mer il s'était
approprié tout cet espace
aujourd'hui faut faire preuve de
commandes de bonne intelligence
est-ce que cet espace il est à partager
avec tout le monde au final l'impact des
turbines sur le milieu marin devrait
être assez limité projetté marins de
commerce et dont j'ai navigué sur des
gros bateaux où il y avait des hélices
de 16 18 mètres qui tourne à 80 à 60 70
80 minutes et qui ont sûrement un impact
autres à mettre du fond sur la rade du
havre par exemple que des hélices de 16
mètres de diamètre qui vont tourner
entre 6 et 8 ans minutes produire à
quelques kilomètres des côtes bretonnes
revient à raccourcir le circuit de
distribution du courant électrique
pour le maire de paimpol cette proximité
permet d'éviter les coupures de courant
lors des grands pics de consommation
l'impact est forcément moins important
de produire de l'énergie à proximité des
territoires que de devoir faire venir de
l'énergie nucléaire d'une centrale qui a
plus de 300 km or c'est bien le problème
de la bretagne c'est le niveau de
dépendance énergétique
on est à 91% dépendant de l'extérieur de
la région forcément le fait de venir
produire dans des sites de proximité
permettra d'éviter cet écueil da la
ferme hydrolienne de paimpol devraient
être raccordés au réseau d'ici juillet
les quatre turbines fournir ou de
l'énergie pour environ deux mille foyers
c'est à dire moins que la population de
la commune pas de quoi concurrencer l
avenir les autres sources d'énergie
et voilà pour ce reportage à paimpol
signé par pierre lascars entre temps
nous a rejoint sur ce plateau michèle
rivasi merci d'être avec nous vous êtes
députée européenne membre du groupe des
verts qu'est ce que ça vous inspire en
fait ce champ d'hydroliennes au large de
paimpol pour l'instant c'est un test on
sait que c'est une technologie qui coûte
cher est ce que c'est une technologie
d'avenir mais sais tu vraiment ce sont
des technologies d'avenir tout ce qui
touche l'énergie marine alors là on n'a
vu l'usiné marémotrice
là on voit les hydroliennes qui a un
intérêt je trouve très important parce
que le courant marin et continue voyez
par rapport à des énergies alternatives
par rapport à des éoliennes en même
temps la france est assez
un peu à l'avant garde là dessus vous
avez vu qu'edf installe quatre éoliennes
je pense que c'est 2013 2014
il ya un plan de faire des fermes
carrément d'hydroliennes et en plus
c'est à proximité voiliers de la demande
par rapport aux villes donc c'est très
prometteur et même si c'est cher à
l'heure actuelle est bien plus on va
multiplier sa plus on pourra le
développer plus le prix va baisser
regardez le photovoltaïque au début il
était très cher puis maintenant il est
tout à fait abordable et on va arriver à
un moment où tout ce qui est énergie
alternative sera beaucoup moins cher
qu'une énergie nucléaire qu'on est
obligé de centraliser avec tout le
problème du transport de l'électricité
donc pour moi c'est il faut vraiment
mettre le paquet sur ces énergies
marines et quand j'ai regardé la carte
européenne
eh bien la france et l'angleterre c'est
là où il ya le potentiel sur justement
les énergies hydroliennes par rapport au
courant qu'ils sont le plus développées
de l'europe donc allons-y
alors on va parler la sortie potentielle
du nucléaire on y voit ce que ça coûte
mais est-ce qu'on a les moyens en temps
de crise économique telle qu'on la
connaît aujourd'hui d'investir sur ce
type d'énergie sachant ce que ça coûte
et bien si vous voulez le problème du
coup il faut regarder au problème de
l'emploi par exemple au niveau d'une
forme de chair mille emplois créés
exactement et ses 10000 emplois créés
sont beaucoup plus importants que les
emplois qu'on peut créer dans le cas du
nucléaire
donc s'il ya de l'argent à investir
parce que là on est dans
l'investissement
voyez à court moyen et long terme cet
investissement sur les énergies
alternatives produisent beaucoup plus
d'emplois que par rapport au nucléaire
donc et au niveau du coup on pourra
après exporté si la france de mes
leaders voyez sur alors on a parlé de
l'hydrolienne mais il ya aussi on peut
produire d'électricité par rapport aux
vagues qu'on peut produire de
l'ex-société même par rapport à une
différence de salinité différence de
température donc il ya un potentiel de
technologies qui peuvent permettre de
fournir de l'énergie notamment au niveau
de la proximité et pas comme l'ancien
modèle qu'on avait c'est un modèle hyper
centralisé alors justement il ya un des
intervenants de ce reportage qui se
faisait un petit commentaire concernant
la capacité de production de ces
machines
on écoute
il nous paraît assez vraisemblable que
il y aura demain des ferme hydrolienne
de quelle puissance et au total combien
la france disposera-t-elle de mégawatts
installée en éolien c'est impossible à
dire aujourd'hui
est ce qu'on connaît ce chiffre michèle
rivasi est ce qu on sait combien on peut
produire avec des hydroliennes écouter
les évaluations café et des fc autour de
3 gigawatts ça veut dire à peu près
trois réacteurs nucléaires mais il ya
d'autres sources d'énergie potentielle
s'est par exemple de l'énergie fournie
par rapport aux vagues
on peut aussi fabriquer d'électricité
par rapport à des différences de
température ou même de salinité
donc il ya un potentiel énorme et puis
il faut plus raisonner monoculture voyez
sur la fabrication d'électricité
il faut raisonner plutôt territoire
c'est à dire regardez tout ce qui est
bretagne où justement il ya un manque
d'électricité on sait que tous les ans
effectivement il ya des il ya des
preuves de rationnement parce qu'il
manque d'électro et puis surtout quand
il fait très froid où il ya des pointes
il ya un an donc si on multiplie voyez
les sources de fabrication d'électricité
en tenant compte des atouts de chaque
région et en même temps en jouant sur la
diminution de la consommation d'énergie
avec des appareils voiliers qui demande
moins d'énergie moins d'électricité qu'à
l'heure actuelle et bien on peut très
bien rentrés dans le cadre de la
diminution du nucléaire au profit de la
multiplication des énergies
renouvelables alors il ya un autre
problème c'est que selon un rapport de
rte donc le réseau de transport
d'électricité on risque d'assister en
fait à des tensions sur le réseau
électrique dès 2016 il va manquer donc
en 2016 1,2 gigawatts et en 2017 2,1
notamment semble-t-il à cause de l'arrêt
de fessenheim est ce qu'on a vraiment
les moyens de sortir du nucléaire
aujourd'hui
habré écouter ça c'est les chiffres que
je voudrais voir de plus près parce que
moi docteur oui s'ils voulaient le gros
souci qu'on a en france c'est l'heure
des points lorsqu'il fait très froid
puisque l'énergie nucléaire civile et la
centrale on peut pas là réajusté en
fonction de la demande donc la première
des choses que fait le gouvernement
c'est de dire il faut isoler les
bâtiments pour qu'ils aient moins de
demandes sur l'électricité notamment le
chauffage électrique
bon en même temps il faut avoir des
appareils qui demandent moins
d'électricité c'est tout ce qu'on
appelle la diminution de la consommation
la demande d'électricité
et puis ensuite il faut diversifier on a
quelques années pour énormément
développer les énergies renouvables
voyez le photovoltaïque il faut que au
niveau des toits au niveau des grandes
surfaces ont pu se développer
psb cette énergie solaire pourtant
regardez le photovoltaïque on a un petit
peu planté je dirais la filière l'éolien
est affilié le gouvernement successifs
après c'est un manque de moyens
certainement ou peut-être un manque de
volonté politique je voyais la question
mais on a vu que donc l'éolien aussi
n'est pas aussi développés qu'ils
auraient dû selon ce qui avait été prévu
en 2007 lors du grenelle de
l'environnement
comment vous expliquez est ce que c'est
un manque de volonté politique qu'est ce
qui se passe alors à mon avis et on l'a
vu sur le grenelle et c'est vraiment un
manque de volonté politique parce que à
la banque de finance aussi peut-être
mais le manque de finances vous pouvez
toujours investir on peut toujours faire
des emprunts dans le cadre de
l'investissement si vous voulez par
rapport à la demande
or on l'a vu sur le photovoltaïque
lorsque on a fait ce moratoire ça a
cassé complètement le développement
moi dans ma région dans la drôme il y
avait plus de 1000 emplois créés voyez
sur l'installation des cellules toutes
les entreprises ont fermé
alors après on me dit mais le prix de
rachat était trop trop élevé mais les
industriels étaient prêts à diminuer le
prix donc il ya eu un manque de vente et
sur l'éolien nous regarder par rapport à
l'allemagne mais il ya c'est un abîme de
différence et l'allemagne revient en
charbon elle sort de l'électricité
nucléaire pour revenir on sent écouté
d'abord elles construisent de nouvelles
centrales au charbon qui émettent
beaucoup moins de co2 et surtout elles
font la transition par rapport au gaz
mais vous voyez que ans dans quelques
années on est à 30 % d'énergie
renouvelable
donc nous moi je pense à quoi je pense à
l'emploi pour l'emploi il faut
développer voyez on a parlé des
hydroliennes tout à l'heure c'est une
source d'emplois incroyable on va faire
de l'éolien offshore
l'éolien offshore c'est plus de 15000
emplois dans toute la région c'est là où
il ya ce potentiel s'est pas encore dans
l'évier énergie obsolète qui nous pose
problème si jamais il ya un accident
nucléaire
donc moi je demande de l'audace il faut
de l'audace il faut de l'investissement
mais voyait productif et puis par
rapport à la demande des gens il faut
d'abord une formation professionnelle et
puis il faut absolument développer des
nouvelles énergies qui empruntent
beaucoup moins de risques ben vous et
merci
celle rivasi on suivra effectivement le
développement ou pas de cette nouvelle
énergie nous c'est la fin de cette
émission on se retrouve dans 15 jours
cette fois ci à bruxelles bonne suite de
programmes sur les chaînes
parlementaires